dire c'était le 14 février la fête des
amoureux et si comme n'importe quelle
femme vous avez eu la chance de recevoir
un bouquet de roses
d'autres ont vu les choses en beaucoup
plus grand c'est le cas du couple thomas
et nabila de passage à paris pour
l'occasion thomas vergara sorti le grand
jeu pour sa tendre et chère balade en
bateau sur la seine
hôtel de luxe dîner en amoureux dans
leur chambre et pétales de roses mais ce
n'est pas tout car en plus de ses
attentions thomas offert à sa compagne
un sublime sac hermès les ceccaldi vie
le birkin cargo le même que la chanteuse
car diby un sac extrêmement rare qui est
aujourd'hui quasiment introuvable dans
le monde
et quand bien même vous le trouverez
encore faut-il avoir 64 mille euros à
débourser
alors alors alors oui alors le prix du
sac 80 mille dollars
alors bon tout le monde a dit oui non
oui non oui non gilbert mais je suis
extrêmement choquée patrol
vous avez beaucoup la question oui pas
de questions oui au sac et non à la
polémique parce que j'ai à vous dire moi
j'ai enquêté aujourd'hui thomas s'est
pas monsieur nabil à thomas il est payé
comme un joueur de foot thomas il a un
salaire thomas ibos il a le droit
d'offrir à ce moment là un sac à sa
chérie comme un joueur de foot ou un
immense chanteur offre un grand bijoux à
sa chérie ça ne me choque pas du tout
c'est dégueulasse on lui fait toujours
des procès d'intention ils s'aiment ils
le montrent comme ça pour moi c'est une
belle déclaration d'amour voilà alors
c'est pas votre meilleur défense
j'aurais dit oui d'autant plus kermesse
est produit en france donc c'est très
bien leurs marges et cité d'autres
marches de sacs bien entendu
maesa que je connais pas d'autres
marques et la présence d'imagés mais
qu'on ne suis pas sûr que il est rouillé
il est payé le ca s'est il a certes il
était vraiment permettre alors qu'ils y
trouvent que la maison la maison fait
beaucoup de placement produit avec des
jeunes influenceurs aujourd'hui on a vu
ryan bensetti sur le site de hermès
on a vu capucine adam dont qui cherche à
rajeunir aussi l'image de la marque
effectivement nabila est une influence
au ski est très suivie et donc
j'aimerais bien être sûr qu'il ait payé
mais c'est après un concert à des
réponses il fallait également chez
hermès
je peux vous dire que hermès n'offrent
jamais l'heure rien on dit aussi vite
ont bien entendu diaw 11 bagues ils
peuvent faire un petit cadeau
quand vous faites un bel achat il pas un
petit cadeau offrir un autre sac par
exemple non mais peut-être notre cadeau
qu'on n'a pas vu je sais pas s'il
cravate ou un truc comme ça en tout cas
il ne faut jamais rien d'accord assez
clair epub
la compagnie cherche c'est tout c'est
pour ça que c'est intéressant parce
qu'il y avait une suspicion
non mais je pense qu'il faut arrêter
d'être aigri nabila et thomas ils
cartonnent ils sont beaux ils
réussissent ils ont fait deux émissions
de télé amazon aura consacré la nouvelle
émission qui va très bientôt sortir il
cartonne ils gagnent très bien leur vie
pourquoi on leur reprochera et combien
même sans placement de produits est
alors ils sont suivis par des millions
de personnes sur instagram et ça c'est
un modèle pour plein de jeunes je vois
pas quel est le problème en plus iran -
des valeurs positives et pourtant elle
ne marque pas c'est à dire qu'elles ne
montrent pas dire regardez mon sac à
65000 euros elle est émerveillée par ce
sac parce qu'il faut savoir que nabila
elle s'en fiche des voitures elle veut
pas de manteau de fourrure elle veut
rien elle a une passion depuis sont à
100 depuis son enfance pour les sacs à
main donc là pour la saint valentin il
lui offre le cadeau de ses rêves ou
dedans a dit je peux mettre le biberon
pour mon petit et allez juste très
heureuse c'est pas ostentatoire c'est
elle le montre juste après c'est sûr
également touché l'europe
j'espère qu'elle sait pourquoi ça
s'appelle le birkin parce que ça c'est
là que moi c'est important mais ouais
parce que c'est en hommage à jack ralite
genre de grands sacs besaces peut mettre
tous à l'intérieur tout ce foutoir ouais
c'est le cinquième édition hommage à
grace kelly aimerait ça je vais te le
dire et le sac on dit bac c'est le sac
andy warhol